today marks the end of the first week of
hybrid learning for clark county school
district superintendent dr
jesus jara says he believes overall it
went quite smoothly although we did
learn
at least eight schools were affected
from positive covid cases among staff
while that is one concern about
in-person learning there are still
concerns about
remote learning vanessa murphy has more
on the issue of privacy which she has
school leaders about
at a press conference today
[Music]
some children are back in clark county
school district
classrooms the first week of hybrid
learning for pre-k
through third grade wrapped up friday
ccsd leaders say more than half of
students are still distance learning
though
mom of six anna binder says she's had
concerns throughout the past year
about remote education in her home there
is no privacy
so we could talk all day long about
intrusion but the way that distance
education is going you have lost all of
your privacy in your own home
and now through hybrid learning there is
live streaming from
classrooms attorney marianne lanudi has
advocated for cameras and classrooms for
years
to help protect students with special
needs particularly those who are
non-verbal
as the i-team has reported two families
also fought for their children to wear a
device called angelsense
which could allow them to listen in live
and to help track their whereabouts
ccsd has fought against cameras in
classrooms and angel sense
citing privacy issues but now audio
and video is shared through both
distance education and
hybrid learning and cameras in the
classroom for non-verbal children
that is my interest to keep those
children
protected so it's really frustrating for
me to understand
how ccsd can
justify that how are you protecting
students
privacy with hybrid learning the
district has fought against
cameras in classrooms now there are
cameras and classrooms
with the live stream so um with
synchronous learning we have to follow
ferpa so we we do not
record any students on personal
identified information
we may we have provided strategies for
our teachers so they are just recording
themselves and the lesson
so we do maintain that privacy you heard
the assistant school superintendent
mention
ferpa there that's the family
educational rights and privacy act
it's aimed at protecting student records
and information
vanessa murphy 8 news now